et si c'était l'année de tahar rahim il
est indéniablement en train de se passer
un truc autour de la performance
phénoménale du jeune acteur français
n'ont désigné coupable il y joue
mohamedou ould salahi à mauritaniens
accusés de complicité aux attentats du
11-septembre et jetés dans les geôles de
guantanamo
une histoire vraie malgré les
interrogatoires poussés
malgré 14 ans d'incarcération malgré la
torture
mohamedou a toujours nié les accusations
désigné coupable raconte son destin tard
l'interprète à la perfection comme le
confirme sa partenaire à l'écran
jodie foster c'est un acteur merveilleux
de tares du moment qu'il était dans
l'espace dans ses quatre murs du prison
j'étais ébloui
il est magnifique magnifique dans le
film et je suis très satisfaite et très
très heureuse de pouvoir faire l'espace
pour lui de jouer ce rôle
pas mal non plus et vous savez quoi
vous n'êtes pas mal d'entre vous savez
moi qui lui merci
là c'est merci
la carrière internationale de dar
démarre en fait il y a un peu plus de
dix ans un prophète le film de jacques
audiard le démarrage de tout pour tard
avait à l'époque très bien voyagé
on voit ici l'équipe du film à sundance
en 2010 avant la nomination d' un
prophète à l'oscar du meilleur film
étranger à hollywood
remarque tard et lui offre son premier
rôle américain kevin macdonald le futur
réalisateur de désigné coupable le
choisit pour jouer dans un péplum il ne
en fait le grand public américain
remarquera vraiment tard dans une série
télé the looming towers sur les
attentats du 11-septembre tard il est un
agent du fbi a glissé que quelque chose
se trame
il ne sera pas écouté mais par contre
les fans de séries américains l'ont tout
de suite adopté les enlever aussi
d'ailleurs puisqu'en ce moment on peut
le voir en tueur en série 3 et 6 cuil
dans ce soft et le voilà donc en tête
d'affiché d'un grand film américain pour
kevin mcdonald il n'y a pas eu de
longues hésitations avant de choisir
tard son acteur de digues en dix ans
plus tôt selon thomas rabe de tahar
rahim est juste remarquable dans désigné
coupable la rolls tout en rage retenu en
enfermement en liberté frustrés et la
presse américaine s'emballe d'art et par
tous les observateurs l'install au
sommet lui il ne s'en rend pas vraiment
compte
si je m'en rends compte d'un point de
vue comment dire le spectateur je m'en
rends pas compte mais moi à l'intérieur
de moi je me rends compte que je veux
que que que je découvre d'autres
terrains émotionnel que que j'arrive à
découvrir d'autres façons d'interpréter
des personnages que j'ai jamais
interprété avant je vis ça comme un
sportif
chaque film je le prends comme un combat
de boxe et chaque jour c'est un monde à
hollywood quand on aime un acteur ou le
met dans la course aux prix la
nomination de tarifs aux golden globes
là
talent dans la compétition pour l'oscar
du meilleur acteur d'arts jouent le jeu
et mènent campagne multipliant les
interviews en virtuel puisqu'il n'est
possible de voyager pour personne c'est
qu'il a sa chance même s'il reste surya
en vrai tu sais jamais vraiment ce qui
va se passer
ce que je sais c'est que j'ai eu lieu de
commencer à me stresser sur ce qui va se
passer de ça je préfère pas y penser
parce que sinon je n'ai pas apprécié ce
qui se passe et ce qui se passe pour moi
c'est extraordinaire ça me fait beaucoup
de bien je suis très heureux il faut le
voir particulièrement ces temps
difficiles et je peux pas reproduire
plus ou moins pour d'autres raisons
l'erreur que j'avais fait avec un
prophète où j'ai pas vraiment apprécié
ce qui s'était passé derrière parce que
je veux j'étais trop vert je craignais
des choses et c'est là je prends
vraiment tout sur le moment présent
le reste ben on verra ce qui se passera
toute manière se passera bien un truc
quoi oui ou non je serais pas resté sur
le moment présent
tahar rahim et donc sera avant peut-être
l'un des plus beaux moments de sa vie
d'acteur les nominations aux oscars
seront annoncées le 15 mars prochain